alors vous savez les 113 canadiens et
québécois ont pu rentrer au pays sur un
vol d'air transat et hier soir eux qui
étaient coincés dans leur hôtel en haïti
depuis plusieurs jours
eh bien il ya d'autres canadiens qui
sont là-bas ou d'autres personnes
d'origine haïtienne qui veulent rentrer
ici au canada et qui sont dans des
difficultés bien sûr c'est le cas de
manuel larigot théodore qui est parti en
vacances avec sa fille de 20 mois le 4
février dernier leur retour au québec
était prévue le 13 février n'ont jamais
pu se rendre à port-au-prince bien sûr
en raison des manifestations
manuela rigaud et théodore est avec nous
ce matin bonjour madame théodore donc
joué en plein alors dites-nous et
caroline lacroix qui vous parle là dites
nous où vous vous trouvez en ce moment
en haïti que hautement chirac en perrin
dans le département du sud de chez eux
l'arrondissement de hawkeye d'accord
donc que vous êtes environ et méditant
200 km de l'aéroport
oui à peu près de 120 ouais bon et vous
deviez prendre un vol au départ le 13
février ça a été remis et là votre vol
du 20 février est annulé parlez moi de
la situation qu'est ce que vous allez
pouvoir faire vous croyez présentement
actuellement je peux juste attendre ou
espérer un avion qui viennent me
chercher pour le vol de lundi
sinon on me les instances mais juste
d'attendre la famille me dit d'attendre
j'ai aucun autre choix que d'espérer que
la situation du pays ça arrange parce
qu'il n'y a aucune possibilité pour moi
qu'on vienne me voyais des ressources
pour le rapatrier est ce que vous êtes
en sécurité présentement que maintenant
je suis en sécurité je suis dans ma
famille d'accord à ce que vous manquez
de nourriture est ce que vous manquer
d'eau potable parce qu'on sait que c'est
la crise actuellement là bas là qu'ils
ont présentement moi je manque pas d'eau
potable nourriture c'est sûr qu'au
niveau de la variété c'est un peu plus
limité les gens m'aiment pour aller
faire leur marché les commerçants
peuvent pas aller chercher tout ce
qu'ils veulent comme approvisionnements
mais on manque de rien tu es d'accord
est ce que vous êtes proche de
manifestations est ce qu'elle ait eu des
erreurs dans le secteur où vous vous
trouvez non moi j'ai dans un secteur qui
est très paisible
puis au contraire même on est
c'est juste les menaces qui ont été
faits à certains par exemple certaines
écoles parce que les écoles doivent être
fermées en temps de grève a tempéré ils
ont tendance à laisser les écoles plus
longtemps verte
il ya eu des menaces de kidnapping si
les écoles étaient fermées par exemple
mais moi j'ai su par je peux a comparé
les manifestations mais vous habiter ici
et vous devez rentrer oui définitivement
j'habite
j'habite au québec je dois rentrer chef
d'entreprise j'ai psychoéducatrice j'ai
une clientèle qui m'attend j'ai des
familles que je veux aller soutenir je
vraiment oui je dois entrer leur maison
lorsque vous êtes parti pour haïti est
ce que vous aviez une idée de ce qui se
tramait ou de ce qui se passait dans le
pays
aucunement aucune en moi pour moi je
m'en aller en vacances
mamère eelv à chaque année je me suis
dit j'ai profité de l'occasion ma fille
va voir son pays d'origine puis surtout
là vous avez communiqué avec le
gouvernement du canada avec affaires
mondiales canada j'imagine qu'est ce
qu'on vous a dit on me dit qu'il n'y
avait pas de ressources nécessaires il y
avait pas de ressources disponibles de
pas faire donc un déplacement qui était
non sécuritaire ils m'ont demandé si
j'avais en effet nourriture eau potable
si j'étais en sécurité puis m'ont
simplement dit que de rester informés
est-ce que vous avez la possibilité de
rester plus longtemps est ce que ça vous
convient de rester là
non ça ne me convient pas pour moi c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment de restituer ce
travail de patience qui fonctionne pas
de mon train de vie actuellement puis je
peux pas me dire que s'il ya du monde
qui voient ça comme positivement sur les
vacances forcées mais j'ai une vie
puisse aussi que des vacances mais
présentement ce n'est plus des vacances
il ya un groupe d'infirmières je sais
pas si vous le savez des infirmières
canadiennes qui se trouve actuellement
en haïti qui ont mené toute une campagne
de sociaux financement les voies
actuellement à l'écran et ils ont amassé
jusqu'à 20000 dollars pour pouvoir
analyser des hélicoptères pour aller les
chercher demain pour les amener à
l'aéroport de port au prince pour
pouvoir prendre un vol est rentré au
pays qu'est ce que vous pensez de ça je
pense que c'est une très belle dimanche
si il était proche de moi physiquement
ça serait ça serait agréable mais la
difficulté c'est vraiment le déplacement
terrestre passe
moi de mon côté j'ai essayé de contacter
des sénateurs qui ont des avions pour
savoir s'ils se déplacent et j'ai essayé
de voir s'il y avait des petits avions
ne court pas très loin qui
habituellement vols qui ne vole pas ce
qui fait que je suis un peu je suis
coincé je suis coincé chez ma mère
finalement j'ai comme en otage et même
les transports routiers refuse de
prendre la route pour l'instant c'est
exact exactement il ya aucun autobus
voyageur ce qui habituellement est le
plus sécuritaire au niveau du
déplacement parce que c'est quand même
quatre heures et demie de route de chez
nous à l'arrêt ou pas mais là il ya
vraiment il ya aucun autobus legend
racer aux sports et avec ma fille devait
moi je voudrais pas non plus monter dans
un véhicule à port au prince faisant
alors on va suivre bien sûr votre
situation annuel à rigaud théodore
espère également que ça se calme malgré
le fait le cas des manifestations
attendues au cours des prochaines heures
et on reste en contact merci beaucoup
nous avons parlé merci au revoir